my name is Josh key Cardoso
I'm 32 years old I'm diagnosed with
schizophrenia I'll be sitting there or
just standing around not really paying
much mind anything and something as real
as I see the person in front of me
talking to me appears it's a suicidal
vision
there always are smiling at me while
they say let's do this we can do this
Shastri you know and Walter smiling at
me there either have a noose in their
hands put around their necks or they're
holding a gun or a knife and during the
process of this you know they're all
just screaming at me to do it
maybe sometimes it doesn't happen too
few days and then I'll come back you
know it's always that my biggest thing
most concerning is we're not crazy
people yes it means would mind you know
Latin like there's something different
there our biggest fear is that yes we
have these visions you know but it
doesn't mean anything
they're not real yes I see these things
but I'm not going to do them